thank you thank you thank you far too
kind what's going on guys
my name is Devin Tommy and welcome back
to the channel if you can recognize that
song at the start of the clip there then
you're in the running to win this
giveaway stay tuned because somewhere
during this video I'm gonna announce all
the details of what you have to do to
make sure you win so if you clicked on
this video for a very specific reason
and you're wanting to find something
about the s20 ultra versus the DSLR I'm
gonna put a bunch of timestamps on the
side here so you guys can quickly jump
to that if you want to know exactly what
you're looking for and not waste your
time so starting off with the camera and
the quality of the photos themselves I
went out today which was kind of an
overcast day with only little pockets of
sunshine so I actually picked a really
good time today to take these photos and
test fit it in all two different
environments I try to test all sorts of
different photography between the two
cameras I went for macro photography
landscape photography photos that
require a lot of dynamic range and
others that are just what you basically
take on it every single day journey at
going down and finding a great landscape
work great memory so I really wanted to
capture a diverse range of different
photos and hopefully I've been able to
do that and give you guys enough
information if not let me know what else
you want to know in the comments down
below and I'll try to make that happen
so looking at the first photo is the
original side by side of the cannon and
the Samsun as we can see both the
originals are pretty good with the
samson kind of having more of a higher
dynamic range with the samsung having a
loo
a better photo from the get-go with this
HDI
F or [ __ ] I see photos that it does
produce and then obviously I didn't want
to just produce straight out of the
camera I wanted to see what these photos
could be edited and how far they could
be pushed but the first photo you can
see that the quality is there in both
the cameras I think the f2000 trial
they've both been image of my style so
obviously if you don't like their
learning style that it's completely up
to you but they've been edited to kind
of match the same editing style I do for
most photos so what one looks like and
what the other should be pretty similar
and pretty consistent in my personal
opinion here the s20 ultra action
produces a better image from afar but as
soon as you start zooming into these
images you'll notice that there is a
little bit of a difference so the second
image here is of the same church the
same position however using the 16
millimeter zoom function on this camera
and the ultra wide on the Samsung is 20
from the originals we can see that the
s20 is using that dynamic range multiple
photo blending to actually get that
Skype brought out straight away in the
raw photo so if you don't have any
editing knowledge or any editing skills
you can actually take a really good
photo first time without having to worry
when we edit both the photos we can see
that the Canon is able to bring back
those skies bring back those overblown
highlights and really lift those shadows
what impressed me the most was the fact
that the Samsung had the same ability
not shooting in RAW but shooting these
hei
C files now these are the photos that I
really wanted to dive deep bit further
into the first photo is looking up at
the church again with the Australian
flag on top shooting through the trees
when you take a raw photo you can see
that the Canon again blows out those
highlights and loses the sky whilst the
Samsung retains that sky and both of
them lose those shadows and blacks go
quite black in
chatters themselves but what's very
impressive is on both devices when you
put them into Lightroom and you adjust
them you pump up to the absolute maximum
you start to see that both the Canon and
the Samsung are able to actually bring
out these shadows to bring out the heart
to bring back the highlight sorry and
actually get some color some contrast
into these images that were previously
just a bit of a dull and boring image
what you start to notice when we zoom in
to the center of the photo is that noise
but then when we move out to the edges
and look at the leaves I guess the best
way to describe this is the Canon camera
produces a more natural kind of Leafs
blowing in the wind and motion blur
whereas the Samsung that goes over the
top and starts to sharpen these leaves
and create defined edges the only way I
can really give you a good example is if
you ever use Google Maps and load up
that 3d version and all you see some
really bad pixelated trees and they kind
of 3d they kind of not that's the
feeling I get when I look at the leaves
and the detail from afar that the AI is
trying to recognize now I'm hoping that
being an AI software it learns it adapts
and the more photos I take like this the
better and better it gets and the better
the software gets with every update so
I'll keep you guys informed with that
but for the time being unfortunately it
is giving that very strange very
pixelated very artificial book so if
you're able to figure out that song at
the very start of this video and
hopefully this video doesn't get to
monetize because of that I want you to
comment down below and tell me exactly
what song that is make sure you like the
video and subscribe to this channel I
will in 30 days go and pick a winner for
the grand prize they aren't even clicked
on this video you're probably thinking
what's the grand prize what a giveaway
well with the samsung galaxy
20 ultra get a set of three galaxy buds
plus now as I mentioned in my past
videos I have no use for this but I'm
hoping one of you guys do so smash the
subscribe button
figure out what that song is and let me
know in the comments below I'm going to
give this about four to six weeks to let
it run its course and pick a winner from
the comments below when we move into
macro photography you notice the
difference in camera quality and actual
image sensor size so obviously with a
big DSLR comes a very big sensor I mean
just looking at the size of the glass
and how big the lenses you're gonna know
that the depth of field is going to be
very short this camera has pretty decent
depth of field but when you compare them
side-by-side you can immediately tell
that the Canon has much better depth of
field and much better focus what becomes
interesting however is when we use the
5x zoom camera on this sampling s20
ultra and zoom in the high quality
photos from Canon the Samsung actually
produces a much higher quality photo in
detail in color in clarity so I was
really thrown off there personally by
the details that have had beside the
church there was also a really pretty
green world that I wanted to kind of
edit to a very different style to see
how far the colors could be pushed on
both devices what was very impressive is
you could kind of get that cinematic
teal and orange look very quickly very
easily from both devices without losing
too much detail from either of the
images and finally an image shooting
directly into the Sun with a subject in
the foreground this is something that
both cameras actually performed pretty
well at but you're going to notice that
the DSLR was able to differentiate the
subject from the Sun from that light
streak coming here
and really get those blacks those
textures a lot better a lot clearer than
the s20 ultra was so from a quick recap
of the photos we've seen so far the s20
ultra is actually pulling its weight
very very well there's only a few
situations where it isn't able to
compete with the big DSLR but at the
same time there is a couple of
situations where it outperforms the DSLR
and had much rather be taking the photo
with the s20 ultra in an everyday
situation when I'm not liking this thing
around now a couple of extra photos I
took with the s20 ultra very quickly
without the DSLR next to me
predominantly for high dynamic range and
color and clarity so the first photo I
took in the car with the coffee out
looking into the sky it was able to
capture both the interior and the
exterior phenomenally I've tried to take
that photo so many times in the DSLR and
they would miserably so the fact that
this photo came out so crystal clear
without any editing and then was able to
be evident exactly how I like it with
minimal effort and minimal distortion
was very very satisfying for me and
secondly I was able to use one of my
presets which I'm not selling dollar I'm
not trying to flog anything off to you
straight away one click and edit it
perfectly how I like it
which means the image quality in itself
is high enough that a DSLRs presets can
be implemented into this photo itself
moving on to the video performance of
this camera and I think I really wanted
to focus here more so on the super
steady aspect and the fact that you
don't have to carry around a Google to
actually get some half-decent shots so
for me I wanted to test very very basic
situations in everyday life that you
might be pulling out a camera or you
might be using in before so both were
tested side by side on top of each other
whatever is working
time without anymore just held in hand
the first one is a very simple test just
panning around in a circle trying to
capture before 360 of that Vista you'll
notice that the s20 ultra produces a
very smooth very usable footage whereas
the DSLR is very jumpy very glitchy and
not something you want to use
professionally personally or anything of
those sorts the second clip here was
filmed specifically before the warp
stabiliser
in Premiere Pro I wanted to take both
cameras down a narrow tunnel where
leading the lines are very important
usually if you have too much shake too
much jumpiness those leading lines get
absolutely destroyed with the warp
stabilizer so this is the clip with the
s20 ultra super steady and s20 ultra
super steady with warp stabilizer now we
also compared those two with the Canon
DSLR no gimbal free hand walking down at
24 frames a second and then we compare
that with a warp stabilizer on it which
does a whole bunch of different things
and lastly I wanted to test the
front-facing cameras 4k capabilities now
the one reason I wanted to do that was
because my DSLR doesn't have auto face
tracking so I have to manually focus
every time I want to go and do a selfie
or start vlogging whereas obviously the
Samsung has some good autofocus and it
also has high dynamic range on the
front-facing camera so this again great
favor ization from the s20 ultra very
very poor quality from the Canon DSLR
what really gets me is the fact that you
get high quality high stability from the
s20 ultra without having to lug around
all your extra needs the zoom test I
guess is more of a gimmick and a way to
sell
camera to the masses and to the public
including myself it is not meant to be a
hundred percent perfect I think it's
meant to be a demonstration of what
technology is capable of and where the
future is progressing if you take a look
at the point five ultra wide camera the
one two five and all the way up to the
30 times zoom on the s20 ultra you get a
really sharp really high-quality image
whereas when you go all the way and push
to the limits from 30-plus to 100 it
kind of goes a bit potato but that's
that's okay I think the purpose here is
I know how I'd use a hundred times oom
for more than anything else except
showing it off and saying hey look it
can zoom a hundred times
I'm never actually going to use that
function and take a photo I really want
to because I've been a landscape
photographer so long and taking photos
with a 16 to 35 I'm not used to zooming
into things and taking pictures of birds
and things like that so for me that's
absolutely perfect I don't need it it's
a gimmick but for me again is the
definition of what the technology is
capable of and where we're heading in
the future so with these two examples
again you can see the third time zoom
really good really clear you can
understand the subject you can
understand what you're looking at keep
in mind neither of these two clips were
filmed with a tripod or with a gimbal
anything they were just held freehand on
top of the car mount of Morocco or
whatever was available so they are a
little bit shaky especially when you get
to the hundred times oom however even at
100 times zoom with the crane for
example you can clearly define that
cabin you can understand how far away it
is what the details are you can gather
enough information from that image what
you can't do is use that image for
social media or use it in a professional
setting and for the last clip of the
test here I was on the road the other
day and wanted to test the audio the
video
quality inside a very bad situation so I
was inside the car with some very bad
road noise and some decent lighting
actually at times were diminished very
quickly so there's three examples coming
up of the front facing camera the rear
facing camera is in decent lighting at
sunset where it's overcast and
beautifully lit in some poor lighting
where the sun's gone down and it's just
the remnants of the light left over from
the day and of course absolute pitch
black darkness to see how much this
phone can be pushed to its maximum so
these three clips a solely for the
purpose of understanding the potential
in different situations and so we've got
some really nice lighting in the car at
the moment it's about 5:30 so and sunset
is definitely about to set I wanted to
pull out the s20 ultra because one we've
got some really bad road noise at the
moment and two I wanted to test the 4k
front-facing camera and the microphone
at the same time so I thought this was
an ideal opportunity for that the same
road test now on the back facing camera
ultra wide I have absolutely no idea
what this is going to be like if it's in
frame if it's in focus one of the
downsides of using the back camera but
it's more of a microphone and a quality
test inside a controlled environment
with some
Royden road noise to finally the rear
facing camera and 108 megapixel main
sensor body is going to be very cropped
in I know that it's probably 90% my face
but I wanted to test all three cameras
in the same situation under the same
lighting conditions and with the same
terrible road noise okay so the sun's
now set and we've gone to a bit of a
dusk time of day where it's not quite
night time yet but I want to assess
camera again here as we can see it's
really trying hard to maximize the
amount of light that it gets and it's
kind of overcompensating by too much
saturation too much exhalation a little
bit of smoothing and sharpening so I'm
going to give it one more test later
down the track when it's absolutely
pitch-black and see what happens then so
this one is pitch-black and the only
light source is coming from the phone
itself I'm guessing this is a bit of an
unfair test because not even a good DSLR
would work here moving to the back ultra
wide camera again for the low-light test
let's see how this looks back at
post-production so looking at all those
details and everything we've just gone
through I think personally on a very
personal note I'm more than happy with
how the s20 objects performed in these
situations and the images that have
produced in the end I wasn't taking a
photographer's eye in any of these
photos or a video of his approach to get
the best shots some good b-roll I was
slowly trying to get good photos in good
lighting and bad lighting to understand
the capabilities for me the s20 ultra
has performed and it is definitely a
phone that I think can replace a DSLR in
every day setting if you're a
professional I think it's going to take
some skill on your behalf to convince
your clients that you're going to be
able to use a smart phone to produce
high-quality images just as good as this
I would also give them the option if
they want to choose both so don't go out
and sell me your DSLR you
professional wedding photographer for
example make sure you stick to what you
know and slowly try to integrate
different elements into your work from a
videography point of view though
I think the s20 ultra hands-down beats
any DSLR right now on the market
especially for people who don't know how
to edit put things together Premiere Pro
color grade etc you don't have to carry
around a gimbal you don't have to carry
around a hundred lenses you don't have
to worry about the footage being blurry
at the end of the day the quality is
phenomenal and I think the video once we
get a few more updates and it'll
autofocus issues get resolved which I'm
hoping there hasn't been too many on
this video I apologize if it has gets
better it will definitely be an everyday
carry for most young refers and most
youtubers I think once the audio it's a
little bit better too
so the conclusion the s20 ultra is
beyond belief and it has been able to
outperform my DSLR in these are very
specific environment settings if you
enjoyed the video make sure you smash
that subscribe button
20:20 style and as always I'll see you
next Monday